yeah thank you very much for this
excellent introduction just want to say
i'm one of the multiple founders of sk
time so there's also
anthony bagnell and marcus learning
to mention
i'm really thrilled to be here in berlin
in person this is actually the first
big presentation i'm giving since corona
in front of people
and as we all know all our social skills
have suffered so if you see me behind
the
desk here don't worry about it
now
i will give the first part of this
presentation which is introduction
tutorial and a tutorial into new
probabilistic forecasting
capabilities of sk time the machine
learning toolbox for learning with time
series daniel will give the second part
on hierarchical and global forecasting
there will be opportunity for questions
after the probabilistic part after
the hierarchical part
these
notebooks there is three in total you
can find them on
this github page it's the sk time org sk
time tutorial pi data berlin
maybe one note ahead
the newest version of the packet which
is required is not yet on conda
which is required to run the binder so
at the moment you should be able but you
should be able to run it using a pip
install or developer install and all the
links for that have been pasted into the
discord of pi data berlin in
this room
and also in general right if you have
any technical problems so you want to
install sk time you think there is a bug
which there of course always might be
i'd say
volunteer driven
project mostly
you can
go to the slack contributor this
sktimeslack the contributor channel or
the discussion forum on the sktime
github
to ask any questions so
um what is sk time if you haven't heard
of it yet it is a psychic like learn
toolbox and really meant to be inspired
by scikit-learn
interfaces in architecture for learning
with time series i'll explain more about
that
below it's open source permissive
license python of course we're pi data
it's openly governed so we're trying to
maintain an approximately equal split
between academic industry and early
career contributors currently we have 18
core
developers
out of which i think you can meet three
here at the conference and a couple more
right now in the slack and discord
channels where num focus affiliated
since recently and also affiliated with
a number of academic centers in the uk
now oh it's openly governed so
contributions are very much appreciated
right here this link gets you to the
getting started and contributors page
you can join our slack and discord
very easily there's regular community
collaboration sessions every friday
there's two currently but depending on
interest
we may arrange more where you can just
join get
asked questions on how to use or how to
install skate sk time
or
join developer discussions
how to start contributing for instance
or just if you want to meet the sk time
developers we'll have
internships this summer
there's a community onboarding event for
those who want to start contributing at
the end of may and we'll have a
developer sprint in june which
which you can join if you want there's
also job opportunities related and
mentoring opportunities related to sk
time so soon
there will be a maintainer job so
maintainer slash researchers as a
combined role advertise at one of our
partner universities the university of
east anglia there's a mentoring program
that's unpaid but you pay in a sense
with your contributions for the
mentoring time there's various options
there and paid internships we're
currently
this year 2022 part as
of google summer of code is an
organization you can still apply there's
one week
that line is april 19. again you can
find details
on
the
mentoring page or if you just go on the
sktime developer documentation you'll
find at the very top and application
link for google summer of code
all right
so
sorry
is it
is it okay can you see this or do you
need to zoom in
can zoom in further is this better
should i zoom in further who thinks i
should zoom in further
who thinks i should zoom out further
who thinks it's exactly right
okay
i'll keep it like this then
so there's a correlation with how far
you are from me i i don't understand why
that is
but you can you can find these notebooks
um also online and you can open it on
your screen
um
all right
so
um psychics learn like toolboxes sk time
is a psychedelic toolbox but what does
that mean and maybe three points i just
quickly want to highlight
to understand the philosophy behind sk
time so what makes psychic learn so
great and one of the cornerstones of
modern
machine learning and ai in practice it's
the unified apis and workflows so every
so algorithms of the same type are
available under the same api they can be
integrated and exchanged in specific
workflows
the individual algorithmic components
are easily composable you can arrange
them for instance in pipelines and the
pipeline again follows the same
interface of the components and it's
open
so open to extension also to third-party
extension it's easy to implement your
own
estimator your own algorithm and have it
interface with all the workflows and
composition patterns you don't need to
contribute to as cyclic learn directly
or there's no license issued attached
because the extension interface the
extension contract is also public
and these three points as well as
specific aspects of the scikit-learn
architecture we're also trying to follow
with
sk time so if you look at
scikit-learn if you haven't seen cyclic
learn yet i would strongly recommend to
look at it so one of the core workflows
i is the
fit and predict workflow the deployment
workflow
or the evaluation workflow depending on
whether the predictions are made
on
data where you already have ground truth
labels supervised learning
um so first right we
load our data x
the rows are
features y
r is a vector of labels of equal length
as x what we want to do is we want to
train an algorithm to predict y from x
on data from a similar source jointly
id formally right in the second step you
specify your model and this can be
arbitrarily complicated can be a
composite pipeline you can specify model
components and build more complicated
models out of the model components
sklearn provides a functional syntax to
combine individual algorithm components
into
into a composite then whether now you
choose the random forest regressor or
any other regression algorithm the
remainder is exactly the same and you
fit to the training data you predict on
the test data so up until four that's
how you would deploy and if you want to
evaluate uh how good your algorithm
performs on historical data on data
already seen you can then run
functionality for
evaluation on top of it right so that's
the basic workflow
emphasizing all algorithm right there's
dozens of algorithms that you can choose
from in scikit-learn and
all the changes if you want to use a
different algorithm here is this part so
instead of 99
trees i could choose 100 and the rest
would be the same or i could write
something much more complicated and it
still would be much the same as long of
course as long as you deal with
supervised regression if it's a
different task you're looking for for
instance clustering then
these steps will change but still they
will be similar morally
as i mentioned already modular model
building so pipeline is is one of the
core pieces that can compose
algorithms into more complex one grid
search is another one which is not shown
here so just as an example this would
then replace step two the model building
step above we have two components a
standard scaler and a k neighbors
regressor which you compose into an
estimator that again has the same
familiar fit predict interface as we see
here steps three four five
okay
so
now
sk time trying to do the same for time
series
and
why is it not just okay now we can just
use psyche to learn for everything the
high level story here there is a
wealth and breadth of
data format so what time series can mean
what it can imply and the wealth of
algorithmic tasks that you can
try to do
or try to solve with time series so
supervised learning is
i think one of the most widely
understood learning tasks but it's not
specifically a time series task in time
series you have this interaction of the
different learning tasks and the
properties of the data format that you
now need to start to deal with so in
consequence it also means you have many
more different types of algorithms and
properties of algorithms
so one example
is the distinction between univariate
and multivariate okay cyclic learn also
has that
as well uh when when it comes to
prediction the other feature is ordering
right so the data are ordered by time
index whereas in supervised
classification supervised regression you
do not have any particular order so in
forecasting you want to forecast into
the future for instance of this time
series and the future time points are
not uh the observations the values are
not coming from
the
same distribution as as the past time
points and past performance is another
guarantee for future performance for
instance you may have heard that
sentence
in time series you also have
multiple observations and then you have
this combination of sequentiality
and multiple types of observations in
this example
so another
maybe more interesting and that's a
significant departure from
the data formats in
in scikit-learn is panel data where you
have
multiple observations over time of
multiple systems or multiple independent
experimental units for instance multiple
patients all being observed over time so
you have the dimension time you observe
one object over time but you also have
the different objects whereas in
classical supervised
learning you have only the object
dimension you do not have the time
dimension so in this setting you have
instances you have the different
variables and you have
and you have time so already you have
three
three
ways three dimensions across which your
observations of variables can vary
and
of course that's only the data that's
not yet what you can do or want to do
with the data
when we get to that
there is also a variation that is in a
sense orthogonal
from
the
the temporality the multiple observation
issues in the data format all right so
for instance we have forecasting you
have a time series you want to predict
ahead in time
we have time series classification so
your samples are entire time series you
want to attach one label to each time
series right so that's
uh that happens on panel data because
you have multiple instances and to each
instance you want to attach a label
that's different from forecasting or
time series annotation tasks for
instance you want you may want to
segment the time series you know inside
the time series
you want to find change points or
outliers or of course you also have
a classif the unsupervised tasks like
clustering within forecasting there are
variations some of which we will see
today
which are common in applications
so you have if you want to forecast you
can do it for a single time so for a
panel you can have additional
information on the time series in
in in sense of a hierarchy
so different units being observed in
those units add up or are contained
hierarchically in other units we'll see
this in the second part and of course
as in supervised learning also there's
the distinction between do you want to
make
do you just want to predict a number or
do you want to predict say a range in
which this number can lie or
distribution
now this wealth of data formats and
learning tasks also comes with relations
between those learning tasks so you can
use for instance an algorithm for task a
to solve task b a very common example in
forecasting would be running over time
series with a sliding window approach
taking these sliding windows and getting
them in x and y format like you have in
supervised regression then applying a
supervised regressor
that act of doing that
as shown in this picture is an act of
reduction the technical term so reduce
forecasting to supervise regression use
a supervised regressor to make a
forecast the supervised regressor does
not become a forecaster but you have two
pieces of the algorithm the supervised
regressor the little robot and the other
part of the algorithm which is an
algorithm composer like a pipeline that
contains the supervised regression
algorithm but itself it's a forecaster
and this act of composition we're also
trying to draw out and make very
explicit
in sk time similar to the composition
constructs that are available in
scikit-learn
philosophically
philosophically we're trying to build a
framework so there's a lot of individual
algorithms floating around and
packages that in a sense are between
individual algorithms and frameworks so
for instance facebook profit is a very
popular algorithm or pmd arima has a
number of statistical
algorithms available for forecasting
with
with varying interfaces and we're really
trying to build to define an api
a unifying interface where we can
present different objects algorithms or
performance metrics under the hood where
you can easily combine them using
composition patterns as we've just seen
in
in the reduction example
and which
also helps to tie an open ecosystem
together
and
currently sk time is a combination of
interfaces to other packages
and algorithms individually implemented
that's a little bit different from
scikit-learn but long-term also
we would like to get to an ecosystem
where we have the
the workflow the interface elements and
then separate pieces of the ecosystems
in which individual algorithms or
composition elements are sitting
right so you can read up more on
frameworks and if you're now interested
extending or presenting algorithms in
the unified format you can also look at
the extension templates and the
developer guides here
there's also i want to mention a
research angle to escape time so we're
also quite involved in academic research
cutting edge research research groups
all over the world make their algorithms
available with sk time compatible format
sometimes directly in sk time and then
using them in benchmarking studies in a
hopefully very reproducible way we have
a lot of community building i mentioned
google summer of code i mentioned the
regular friday sessions so you are very
much welcome to join that journey all
right that's the introduction
and then i'll proceed to
probabilistic
the new probabilistic features how we're
in terms of time
all right so
um probabilistic forecasting
next notebook
to them
so this notebook has more content that i
then i will be able to show
in the time but it's it's more there for
a completeness it's still meant as a
tutorial notebook so what i will show is
a quick start
some explanations of what does it even
mean to make probabilistic forecasts
right sometimes a lot of different
concepts are
bunched together under this
heather then how do you do probabilistic
forecasting in sk time metrics and
evaluation advanced composition and at
the end is an extended guide i only skim
over that
all right
so
probabilistic forecasting with sk time
philosophically as we've said we want to
stick to scikit-learn-like interfaces
which means we have designed our
workflows very much around this this is
the non-probabilistic workflow
looks very much the same with
slight differences to the scikit-learn
to the scikit-learn interface so for
forecasting
right you only fit to
a
part of the past time series and
possibly exogenous data
so that's the x but it's not um it's not
shown here and the forecasting horizon
which is a representation of the time
indices
for which you want to make a forecast so
for instance
if you look at
if you look at the airline data on the
previous slide remember these were just
observations monthly up until the year
1960 or so and now we say okay we want
to predict from this y three month ahead
that's um
january 61 february and march
and
the predict interface here would give us
0.4 costs so just one value
per
per month so you can see all of that in
the general pi data global
the pi data global tutorial for sk time
which you can visit here
using the link at the top of the first
notebook but the probabilistic interface
works like that so for instance we can
use this function predict interval
with and and giving to it a nominal
interval coverage for the forecast and
it will forecast a
lower
and an upper value
of an interval with this nominal
coverage 0.9 so
we expect in this case for instance uh
zero zero five five percent
probability nominal probability for the
value to fall below and five percent
nominal probability for the value to
fall above the upper here so that's the
general gist of it it works exactly like
the non-probabilistic interface
and now let's look at the different
methods in sk time that are available
for probabilistic forecasting there are
currently four different methods
corresponding to different kinds of
probabilistic forecasts which i will
also explain in a moment it's just a
quick start so predictive intervals are
available under predict interval we have
forecast quantiles and these forecast
quantiles are at quantile points or
quantile values the forecast intervals
are symmetric and at a given coverage
forecast variants can be obtained using
predict underscore var and depending
whether you have cov equals false or not
you get marginal variances or a
covariance matrix of the forecast
the full distribution forecast using
tensorflow distributions as a return
type can be obtained from predict
probably and up until the uh
specific
arguments so for forecast intervals you
have coverage for quantiles you need to
give it the quantile points you want to
predict at up until then the syntax is
exactly the same
as for the point forecast and their
sensible defaults for
the
probabilities for the specific arguments
so coverage for instance will default to
90
and the quantiles will default to 0.05
and 0.95 quantile points which will give
you
um except for interpretation exactly the
same as the default for the forecast
intervals
which forecasters support
probabilistic forecasting can be
retrieved by using the all estimators
registry function you need to filter
tag capability predictive interval if
that tag is true then the forecaster in
question implements either by default or
by native implementation
the all four probabilistic prediction
methods all right so um so this method
may take a while to run because it may
have crawl have to crawl through the
entire package some of these are
compositors in the case of a compositor
such as a
pipeline it means that depending on
components it may or may not support it
but logic is implemented if all is good
for the components
so for instance the
pmd arima models or
facebook profit support probabilistic
forecasts out of the box
okay that was the quick start now this
ambiguation what is probabilistic
forecasting
intuitively we want to produce a range
of scenarios or an uncertainty around
the forecast
so what does it mean what is
what is the range of variation or the
nature of variation in the value that we
expect to observe in the future and it's
a query to an algorithm you ask the
algorithm what do you think are going to
be high in those scenarios which in the
algorithm doesn't need to be right
obviously always the algorithm can be
wrong it's what the algorithm tells you
and different algorithms obviously also
will produce different
probabilistic forecasts
from an interface view
from an interface view
we do the same as in point forecasting
so we specify
the series we want to forecast the
values of it specify exogenous data
which may or may not be observed or
known up into the future we specify a
forecasting horizon which encodes the
indices
at which we want to
[Music]
obtain forecasts
at and that is exactly the same as in
point forecasting which is covered as
i've said in the basic tutorial a
recording of that is available from pi
data global 2021.
now the key difference here is the
output of predict right we have these
four different predict functions and
depending on what you're asking from the
output will be
in meaning or in format or in both well
always in meaning but in format
sometimes different from what you get
from the point forecast function predict
so it's going to be some object that
encodes
the
probabilistic forecast which could be as
we have just seen
a sequence of interval
forecasts of lower and uppy values for
the quantiles or it could be a full
distribution
right and there's also a formal view on
this which i just
skim over idea four different kinds of
probabilistic forecasts that we're
currently supporting and conceptually
looking after
and that corresponds in a formal view to
con the variance forecast is a
conditional variance conditional on the
data observed as predicted by the model
quantile forecasts are the
uh quantiles of
the predictive distribution interval
forecasts are obtained from quantiles in
a symmetric way so for a given coverage
you want a symmetric interval where
lower and upper excess
are of
equal probability
nominal probability a distributional
forecast
returns in a symbolic manner you're
asking for a symbolic representation of
the law or the distribution of the
conditional where the y prime here the
future
data that you're trying to predict y is
the data you have observed
and all this has a true distribution and
we're asking for a prediction or an
estimate of it we're asking the
algorithm for a prediction or an
estimate of it
quickly to note different forecasts has
different capabilities
given that we have a variation over the
return objects here but we also have
different metrics so now we need to
compare for instance a
conditional variance prediction with an
actual that is not a variance the actual
will be an observation it will be a
sample from the true y prime and we will
see also as compositors that can just
add functionality to add a type of
forecast like the bootstrap
okay i'll skip this there's a bit of
intuition on the formal side here you
can read through it and there's also
references
mentioned at the bottom
frequent points of confusion perhaps to
mention
there's different concepts here
which are relevant
in using these definitions lower upper
interval forecasts are equivalent to
quantile forecasts at quantitative
points 0.5 minus coverage or plus
coverage half
up
except of course for for the
interpretation for a symmetric interval
if you predict if you have a full
symbolic representation of your
distribution then of course you can ask
it for quantiles or you can ask it for
for mean and variance a full
distribution in codes both the point
forecast and the quantile forecasts
in general so except for that there's no
exact relation
between the different types of forecasts
so for instance a point forecast which
is a mean forecast in general does not
need to be equal to the median forecast
which would correspond to a quantile
point of 0.5 and in general the mean of
a distribution can be smaller or larger
than any
quantile as long as it's not 0 or 1.
there's
just to keep that in mind
if you look at the different packages in
the ecosystem and we've had a number of
bugs ourselves as well because we as
developers ourselves
found that confusing it's really
important to get this right the common
confusion is coverage versus the
quantile of the lower
the coverage where the significance so
that's a one minus right so we had for
instance a bug where um
when you made the coverage bigger then
the intervals became narrower but that's
just because the interfacing
was was done wrong
and getting all these things into a
consistent interface format is also a
bit of a challenge
there's also bayesian posteriors or
confidence intervals on the predictive
mean which should not they're also
intervals but they shouldn't be confused
with predictive intervals
again they all have formal meanings
i would recommend to read up on it if
you're interested in probabilistic
forecasting the devil is really in the
details
okay
so
back to doing that in sk time
having a look at the various interfaces
so i'll look at
one
general thing the prediction methods
they don't change state
so if you want to ask for multiple
forecasts or a point forecast and a
probabilistic forecasts just call for
instance predict and predict underscore
interval
so up until the probabilistic prediction
the fitting works exactly the same of
course you need to use a forecaster that
supports probabilistic forecasts we have
data loading define a forecasting
horizon construct the forecaster and fit
it
now
then you have to run
the
probabilistic prediction method and
specify the extra argument say if you
want a coverage in predictive intervals
that is different from the default value
here
so let's say we want coverage forecast
interval forecast it will look like this
just called predict interval
and
so that's the return that you get get
the column lower upper and you can give
it a vector of coverages and then you
will get here the second level here in
the return
we'll have different coverages and each
of them will have a lower upper if you
have multiple variables you get multiple
values in the first column corresponding
to variable names
you can of course also plot it
and then you get a nice interval
forecast
so multiple coverages as i've said you
can vectorize over coverages try the
same for the quantiles in the quantile
forecast and of course then the return
object will expand it's always a
partners data frame except for the
distribution forecasts which were the
multi-index of
the column
ranges over potentially variables and
coverages or alphas
predict quantiles really much the same
but now it's quantized and not coverages
and because it's quantized they don't
have a lower and upper
same thing
so this is
this plot shows
five quantas being forecast
10
25 percent median so it's
the
quartiles
except
the
min and max
that's only that's usually going to be
at infinity and 10
90 percent
plotted here
predictive variances there's just one
predictive variance of the marginal one
just looks like the point prediction but
these numbers of course are variances
and as you see
here send very sensibly the variance
increases as the predictive variance
increases as you go forward in time
because the further it is in the future
there's certainly the algorithm
is about it
if it's a sensible algorithm
if you want the covariance you get a
covariance between
forecasting
horizon indices
at the column and at the row
predict proba gives you the full
symbolic representation of a
distribution you need to have tensorflow
installed for that and the
the return type is a tensorflow
distribution
if you are familiar with tensorflow if
you want to ask for a marginal
probability prediction you have a bad
shape
that corresponds to the forecasting
horizon length
and
it's in the same sequence in the batch
index the event shape corresponds to the
variables so you can also model of
course
association
correlation between the different
variables
but you don't get modeled association
between the different time points of
course that's useful for instance if you
want to compute something like
a logarithmic loss where you need the
marginal distribution if you want
marginal if you set marginal equal false
you get the full joint distribution
predictive distribution over all time
points and
variables that's not implemented for
many of uh
that's not necessarily implemented
currently because not many methods
support that that's interface-wise as
i've said philosophy is designing an
interface that you could
implement against as you get back here
a wide red dist there's no tensorflow
distribution for the specific
model the theta it's a normal
distribution so you can ask it for
quantiles and that should be consistent
with the quantile prediction and you can
ask it for parameters so you get
location and scale which in this case
will be mean and standard deviation of
the marginal distributions in the
prediction
caveat
the different methods do not always need
to be consistent with each other some
algorithms also have a randomness in
them
and
that means even if you repeat them you
might get different results and
quantiles may cross over as well if the
method itself doesn't
doesn't prevent that you can use
probabilistic forecasts in the update
predict in the streaming workflow where
you start with data then let's say time
progresses you update the model with
more data than to predict in the
following way so let's say we start at
end of 1950 and we want 12 months of
predictions ahead and every month we
want to update the 12 month of
predictions
so our three data batches with which we
update look like this
okay so first if we want to do this then
first we need to fit
to the first batch and the first
prediction is obtained by predict
interval and at each subsequent step we
make an update
and call predict interval again
and we do this as many times as we want
so it works while with the update
predict workflow just to explain what
we've done right we've expanded our data
window this is the blue thing here we've
added one more
row and made a prediction across the
12-month forecasting horizon which is
orange so orange is the places the
indices where we make predictions for
it's multivariate and hierarchical i
skim this
over
i skim over this
different variables and hierarchical
indices we'll see this in a moment they
have row and column indices
and it works for all
the forecast types
metrics
so the metrics again i skip over this
sk time currently implements a few
metrics for interval and quantile
forecasting
the pinball loss for instance
and those metrics work exactly like
point prediction metrics
the general form of how we evaluate the
metrics
keeps the general form of metrics
so first argument is the
true observed the ground truth
observation
the second
argument are the predictions but those
predictions can take different forms
so for quantile forecast it will be the
data frame that contains the quantiles
for distributional forecasts it will be
the tensorflow distribution it contains
the symbolic representation of the
distribution
and just like the point prediction
metrics we have classes
and those classes can be
you can be called using a function
interface
all right so for instance
if we
run the if we instantiate the pinball
loss class
can then
instantiate it as
with the functional interface why true
why pred the predictive quantiles are
what comes out of predict quantiles of
the estimator and then depending on how
we average right all
losses have differ you can set the
weight to average
and you get the loss by quantile point
or the average overall quantile points
or by sample
so you can also get just a table of all
the losses
i'll skim over that
and
that way it's fully compatible with the
tuning interface
and the evaluation interface so you can
stick now these probabilistic losses
in the evaluation interface just like
you could any other loss you need to
provide in the scoring argument the
evaluation interface will automatically
recognize what type of a loss it is so
if you stick in a interval loss it will
call the predict interval interface of
of the estimator
you can use it in
pipelines for tuning
and i want to mention because i'm
running slightly out of time some
advanced composition patterns here there
are estimators compositors which you can
use to add probabilistic prediction
capability to any estimator so for
instance the naive variance estimate
over the residuals
as you just take this compositor naive
variance you stick your favorite
forecaster in but this one doesn't have
probabilistic prediction
but after you stick it in this wrapper
um it does have the capability so
there's some logic implemented works
exactly like the reduction picture the
wrapper and the small thing inside
then you can call it with the familiar
interface and of course this is not the
only way you could add right you could
use the bootstrap that's
not implemented yet but contributions
are very much appreciated so there's a
lot of interesting research around for
instance how you turn
your deterministic your point
forecasters into probabilistic ones
you can use it in tuning in automl so
just exactly the same
compositors you just pass a
probabilistic score and it does the
tuning across the probabilistic score
forecasting grid search here
right and the predictions just work like
with the same interface
automl for multiplex work using
multiplex forecaster works exactly the
same as in the deterministic case
pipelines work exactly the same
and i also skim over that you can have a
look at it in the notebook
here's some points if you want to build
your own probabilistic forecaster
you can look here at the details we have
in implementing your own estimated
developer guide there's a few extra
points to look out for they're all also
mentioned in the extension template i'm
just highlighting them there for your
own use
the check estimator utility
can run as in the ordinary case
to check which tests are running
so we have unified interfaces as a
summary for probabilistic forecasting we
have probabilistic metrics interfaces
for evaluation they work out of the box
for all the composition patterns that
you are familiar with in sk time
for 0.4 casting including the composite
model building interface it's also
easily extensible you just need to
implement
one of the probabilistic functions
there's some resources here
and
a lot for your questions
um
we just had uh one question on slido
about where to find your notebooks
yes
so where to find the notebooks has been
posted in the discord channel for this
room just go to the discord channel for
this room it's also
at the start
here
this is the link
on the sktime org
all links have also been posted in the
pi data berlin discord channel
for this room which is a5 a6
time for another quick question
in the uh
thanks
just a quick question on on the training
data and what experience you have or how
does it deal with data gaps what i see a
lot is that the training data is
incomplete so you
like the times in between
might be different um so
you're lacking a sample form so if you
have missing data or
irregular sampling you can just stick
your estimator in a pipeline that deals
with those aspects or you can try an
estimator that natively deals with
irregularly spaced data
so for instance
we have the imputer
so the imputer if you pipeline it with a
forecaster it first imputes the missing
data and then runs a forecaster which
might not deal with missing data or you
search for forecaster just have the
missing data tag and and those are
forecasters that out of the box can deal
with missing data
thanks a lot
for this presentation we'll welcome next
uh next
next speaker daniel brackling and that's
why the speaker is setting up um yeah
just a reminder that we collected the
question on
slido.com and to join the conference the
hashtag is bybear p-y-b-e-r
thank you okay
so thanks a lot um
my name is daniel bartling i
work at this as a data scientist at
mercedes-benz aeg
mercedes-benz is also a github sponsor
for sk time i think one of many um just
like testament to the great um
i can take that off all right
um to the great potential i think
many in the industry see in sk time i'm
going to speak about hierarchical
global and panel forecasting
um yeah the we will first talk about the
general problem of hierarchical time
series and and why it's useful to have
uh specific tools uh to model those
uh we will talk about hierarchical and
panel data formats and ski time how
ascii time represents um these formats
and we also talk about
the vectorization of forecasts and
transformers hierarchical reconciliation
which is very important in this context
global forecasting
we'll take a look at also one of the
challenges of these models
that we try to address here
and finally we talk about the extender
guide similar to the way france just
presented
so maybe first of all just some
background uh what is a hierarchical
time series why does it matter
so in business cases or in general or
other domains we often have the
challenge that we have
different structures of hierarchies um
we have
um maybe here for example as you can see
uh for product sales we have some
products that are in certain categories
these categories add up to groups of
categories and we have a total and
depending on the problem we are
sometimes very much interested in the
lower level sometimes very much in the
upper level but sometimes also in all
levels and
this is not trivial that we have
estimators that perform well at all
levels of the hierarchy and at the same
time add up because of course
um often when we we want to present a
finally a result and then the first
question of course is why doesn't it add
up if you produce very good accurate
results at each level but in the end the
picture is not
correct and clear then you are
in an ish have a problem often to you to
explain your solution
so
okay
so then we talk about a representation
of hierarchical and panel data types
so in ascii time we talk about three
different categories we have here we
have series panel and hierarchical
formats
series is when you really consider every
time series individually
panel formats
is when you have typically
an identifier you're mainly interested
in an identifier you have multiple time
series that you are considering but you
are interested in an identifier that
tells you
to which time series now your
observation belongs to your tracker
panel of consumers across a certain
length of time for example and
hierarchical finally is the
example that i just showed where you
have can have an in large number of
different hierarchies at the same time
um
so for simplicity we have different
formats of how to represent data in
ascii time but we will now focus on the
pandas data frame format
in that case um and
we call that information
um
yeah um here we take we take some
examples that we are interested in um to
see how these these data types are
represented so first of all we have the
pandas data frame representation i think
the only important missing thing
for the series type is that we have
always an intex index this must be a
monotonous it can be an integer it can
be a range
it can be also
a daytime index or a period index and we
can have an arbitrary number of columns
that
represent the time series that we are
interested in
so for example in this case we have only
one time series
and an integer index we can also have a
bivariate case where we have two time
series at the same time also an inter
integer in the index so that's the the
base type we're interested in and next
we take a look at the panel type as i
mentioned here we are mainly interested
in tracking the different
instances to which an observation
belongs to
instance in in this case means the
unique identifier of the time series so
for example which person are we now
tracking in the panel
and here we have a two column
multi-index and the second index always
corresponds
to the time period to the time point the
first index is always our identifier
so the second index has the same the
time points index has the same
restriction it must obviously the second
index
the algorithm rhythms get confused so
here you can have an example of how that
looks like
we have two variable variables we have
the time points again integer and we
have in this case uh three instances uh
corresponding to three different time
series that we are looking at
and finally we have the hierarchical
side type
call here pd multi-index higher
and
basically just in the extension of the
panel type
we have always the last index must be
the time points index and
the indexes indices before can refer to
the hierarchy so here for example um we
would then have maybe the products here
in bar and the product groups in foo
to to track
where everything uh belongs to
um
so you can access
these kind of indices so what what do we
want to do with that um now one approach
that we could do is we simply want to
fit
a forecaster to every time series that
we have here individually
so we are not interested in
modeling any hierarchies having any
groups we simply want
that our models are applied
independently to every instance we have
here and this can be done for this
example data set that we are have loaded
here
that conforms to the structure i already
explained
when we
simply
call a forecaster just in a general way
we would do that on this data set then
it recognizes um our ascii time
recognizes that there is a certain
structure a certain hierarchy in this
data set and it will maintain that
structure
and fit now individual models to every
instance we just described all of these
uh individual independent uh riema fits
um
and um
so here's there's currently so the added
benefit is here now okay we just provide
the data frame it will automatically
detect that hierarchy and then provide
the forecast so we had a forecast
horizon of two so you can see here uh we
will always have the first two
observations corresponding to that
you can access all these individual
forecasters you can easily see that
every fit is independent so every fit
has also its own parameterization so you
can take a look at that
and see how that differs across the time
series
um
and you can even
what france just showed you can even
take a look at
prediction intervals in the same way and
then you will get the prediction
intervals for the forecast derived in
each group
independently
um
we have an internal representation for
that if you want to take a look at the
forecast and you can then you can take a
look at this inner m type and it will
tell you what kind of forecast that is
is it a forecaster that just
can be applied to a series well what we
mean by that is it is a focus that it
doesn't understand or doesn't explicitly
model any hierarchical information so uh
ski time will then automatically apply
when it encounters such a hierarchical
format it will automatically vectorize
and automatically apply independent fits
we could talk about different models in
the future for example we are going to
implement
mixed effect models that can understand
hierarchies and then you will encounter
here different data types and then also
the fits won't be
independently vectorized but will
recognize that there is some added value
to be drawn out of the hierarchy
there's a vast array of different kind
of internal representations that are
relevant here
we are not going through all of them but
you would encounter them as we saw now
for arima just pd series and you would
encounter different types for example
multi-index here for a forecaster that
can explicitly draw
upon that
information
so what are we going to improve
implement here
we talked about
providing forecasters that really
explicitly model hierarchies um also
telling maybe the focus to be able to
use the hierarchy levels simply as
coverage i mean that's something you can
of course do in arima that you give the
information about the hierarchy as a
covariate
but
exactly that's that's something also
multivariate models like vector auto
regression can can then be fit
to all time series at once
now what we next talk about is
hierarchical reconciliation so i already
mentioned typically in a problem it's
it's a not not a good situation if the
hierarchies don't add up of course
that's very difficult to explain even if
every high uh
forecast forecaster that you produced
maybe has a good quality on its own if
they don't add up then that's often a
very undesirable um
feature
so what you can do of course always is
what we call bottom-up reconciliation
you only model the lowest level of the
hierarchy so for example you only model
products
and then
you would simply add up all the products
to the total
and that then of course is consistent
but you often have the issue that maybe
at the product levels there's a very
very high volatilities
products are phased out phased in
some maybe out of stock or something
like that so you have a very high
volatility when you just model at a
product level and this volatility it
adds up
resulting in a forecast at the top level
of the hierarchy your total which maybe
is really stable and has a nice
seasonality and pattern but suddenly
it's a very wide forecast with it varies
in a very significant way so that's
depending on the problem can be a good
solution but often is not very desirable
there's another method just from the
other way you only model the top level
of the hierarchy and then you just take
a look at certain proportions
maybe
of
of the lowest level how high is the
proportional share of the lowest level
and you just break down the top level
but that of course ignores any
peculiarities you have maybe some
products at the lowest level are very
seasonal some not so you are not able to
model that so that's also not really
desirable
and therefore
what we are supporting here and what in
general i think is like a bit of a
standard is an optimal focus
reconciliation you produce forecasts at
all levels of the hierarchy and then you
adjust all of them to some degree and
there are different algorithms and
different weightings that you can apply
here then ultimately you have focus that
typically produces
a good focus at all levels but adds up
and i think that's
a very desirable
property here
sktime
provides two functionalities that are
important in this
regard the first is the aggregator so um
simply adding up or aggregating up in
the original time series starting from
the lowest level to the top level and
the other one is the reconciler that we
just mentioned so whenever you adjust
forecast at certain levels of the
hierarchy then you would use a
reconciler and we will now take a look
at how that looks like in practice
so um
we always have um what the aggregate or
what we always need in this regard is a
total level so what what we showed you
uh before is um this fu bar structure
where you have a bar is the identifier
of the individual instances and through
would be like the categories and what
you can add and introduce here and uh
what we have in this example is a total
row so the total row always uh refers in
this in the first line here now to the
total at the top level of the hierarchy
or to subload totals that you can see
here in a
total and that would be the subtotals
that you
implement so that would be a
representation but of course we often
don't start at that so data set
typically doesn't start at this
time compliant aggregation
and that's why we have an aggregation
transformer so
we we already saw the aforementioned
problem we passed the hierarchical
information into the multi-index and
now we don't have of course this total
structure and that's why we take the
aggregator and that is what the
aggregator does for us
so um when we fit and transform the
aggregator to the data set then we will
get all these totals and we will have
this compliant as time representation of
how we
would then represent the generation of
all the levels of the hierarchy
and what we can now do is for example uh
we take any forecaster that we have and
that's an i think a relevant feature i
think there are other libraries where
it's kind of linked that you have at the
same time to specify the forecaster and
the aggregator but here you can take any
forecaster you want and combined with an
aggregator functionality and then this
example here we would first apply the
aggregator we would first generate this
aggregation structure and then we apply
a forecaster and that would be the first
case that i discussed that you do a
forecast at every level of the hierarchy
at the same time but this has the
aforementioned problem that it doesn't
add up
an alternative way and this is
corresponding to this bottom-up approach
that we now mentioned is to first fit to
the non-aggregated data set of
forecaster and then
add the aggregator after that and then
you will get fully consistent
forecasts that correspond to the
bottom-up approach so there's no
reconciliation at this point because we
don't adjust anything
and the advanced reconciliation on the
other hand that would be
using the functionality of the
reconciler so we can first fit for
example the aggregator then the
forecaster and then a reconciler and
this is now
an ordinary least squares reconciler i
think we have currently implemented
also a wait wait at least squares
um
reconciler and then we would have this
mentioned
behavior that all forecasts at all
levels of the hierarchy are adjusted so
we have at the same time relatively good
forecasts at all levels of the hierarchy
and this coherence that we want
so what is the the road map or where we
do want to go do we want to go
there's a technical
issue here if we currently uh in the
book of heinman which is like the
standard there are several
reconciliation methods with the current
structure of the pipeline we are not
able to implement all of them so that's
something we just want to extend in this
away we also want to
implement more reconcilers
as a result of that
that we have more different methods
and we also want probabilistic
reconciliation which means like what
france just showed that we have this
confidence
intervals or quantiles and of course you
can do also
hierarchical reconciliation across
different forecasts
and different quantile forecasts so
that's also something that we are
working on
now i will show the next uh use case
which is global forecasting um global
forecasting what do we mean by global
forecasting
um global forecasting distinguishes it's
uh from univariate forecasting because
you do not fit um
individual
time series
always in an independent way but instead
you pass a lot of time series um to a
single forecaster
why is that desirable
first of all in the time series domain
we often have the issue that
um we don't have so much observations
going back in time so that's typically
just a problem maybe we just started
collecting the data and therefore
sometimes it's very difficult to
implement complex models we know for
example we want to forecast production
volumes in a plant
and we have information complex
information about the production program
we have
information about the capacity but if we
now do individual forecasts for every
time series then it's very very
difficult for the time series to
understand the relationship between the
volumes that are finally resulting and
all this information you want to feed
inside maybe you know really a lot about
how your process works but simply
because you don't have so much
observation going back into time often
it's an issue to to to
help the forecaster understand that
information and that's where global
forecasting comes into play so here the
idea is that we fit if we are able to
observe
i don't know
hundreds or thousands or ten thousand or
several thousand uh of the similar
processes similar productions of items
similar evolutions of balance sheet
accounts different accounts and you
think there's some similarity between
the
data generating process behind
generating uh that and then you can feed
everything off into a global forecasting
model and suddenly you have a much
larger database and you can also model
much
more complex
relationships
this doesn't work of course if the main
driver is the evolution of time and
because that's something you can't
extend but if it's simply because you
didn't observe your process enough times
because there are some relationships
independent of uh now i don't know and
the purely time driven uh way then this
works very well and that's why
also um
we have a very good performance of these
models in many competitions that are
relevant here
um so we take a look at
one example that's based on the
popular m5 competition here we can say
okay we model every product by certain
instances
um so
this is uh how for example the y now
looks like and at the top level so we
have this instance structure we have the
time stone structures and that conforms
to products and we have lots of
exogenous information also in in the
same way
with instances identifying whether this
information belongs to
and we model this with the panel data
type that we already mentioned
and
we we we can use all this kind of
exogenous information so what we first
do is again apply apply this temporal
train test split and this will now
understand that there's um a structure
that there's uh there are different
instances so it will split every
instance conforming to that structure so
in train we have always for all
instances the same time points and then
test we always have the same time points
um
we will now explain
how we um
how we implemented uh what uh our four
custom that uh that we chose for this uh
was a 3 based model typically tree-based
models have issues in universe
forecasting because they don't have so
much data they are very good at modeling
uh complex dependencies but in global
forecasting as we said we have lots of
data for example mm5 i think in total we
had 43 000 time series
uh ascii time supports all kinds of tree
based models we just have a random
forest regressor here
and but what is the big caveat here
these models are
not really designed for time series
tasks so they are assuming every
observation is independent in principle
kind of
and that's why we need to provide
information that captures the time
series dynamics and for that we
implemented a windows summarizer that
constructs features that help
the algorithm understand the time series
dynamics so for example with this
notation that we sped up specified in
the dictionary we are able to generate a
lag we are able to generate a rolling
mean calculation across a window of
length three or six in this case and
lagged by a period of one and three and
we can also calculate standard
deviations that way um so that that
would what would be the notation here we
use for the windows summarizer always uh
referring to the for observation i want
to forecast and and generating then
different functions
and by default we have implemented all
the pandas or you can access all the
pandas native rolling window functions
which are very fast when you apply them
in this group by fashion and also
parallelized
but you can also provide your own
functions i think what was very useful
is for example providing means of
different window length and different
lags
to understand what is the level of the
forecast you want and also maybe if you
track different windows you can see the
tendency
but also things like skewness or
kurtosis were very helpful to also see
the the tendencies where your forecast
should go but you can also provide every
every function that you think is usable
or it makes sense
typical examples in the m5 was counting
how often how many serials you had for
example but you can define anything and
provide it here and then this will be
okay also implemented um and um will
track um
exactly um how it looks like so here for
example everything that is above 700 i
think the column name is wrong but the
function definition is correct
um you can also apply this window or
summarizer not only so this was about
helping your model understand
the evolution of your why so that you
would understand give it a
sense of the time dynamics but you can
also apply the same of course the
exogenous features so maybe
you think it's relevant what
was
lacks about holidays for example the day
before a holiday often is also relevant
when you want to model sales because
everyone buys more
and the same
for maybe sales prices or things like
that and then you can use the windows
summarizer in a forecasting pipeline say
telling it which exogenous
information you want to cover you can
also specify different dictionaries
different functions that you want to
have applied
and then this information
will be used so that's the other
implementation of that windows
summarizer now if we want to
implement that
in the in our
yeah for our
[Music]
typical problem then we use a make
reduction function what that normally
does is it provides for every
observation
that you want to forecast it provides
all past observations just as raw values
you can specify a window length of 20
and then you will get the past 20
observations
but
raw without any feature engineering but
if you want but this is typically not
very efficient because um you kind of
cannot really model the time dependence
just by passing raw values uh at least
not with three base models and that's
why you typically want to
apply your windows summarizer which will
then maybe instead of the 20 raw values
give you the
mean of the past 20 observations and the
standard deviation of the past 10.
whatever you specify here and you can
specify
in within the make reduction functions
uh that windows summarize it will do
that work for you
another feature that also is relevant
and it is also not understood by tree
based models by default is calendar
information
so if you just pass a date column
there's not much information that can
extract from it it will convert it to an
integer and that's it you typically want
to provide information about it
day of the week effects can be very
relevant maybe seasonalities
they're being different in spring and in
summer
months beginning can be different two
months and due to salary effects all
these kind of things you want to model
and for that we have a daytime features
um
transformer and that will then take a
look at the time points column and
generate features that are relevant here
so you can just call it and pass the
frequency and then it will automatically
generate some sensible features in this
case for daily data you get month and
weekday but that's an automatic
functionality
we support this kind of period this uh
or yeah periods currently
and you can specify everything every
period that you wanted that you think is
relevant so for example when you say i'm
interested in the week of the month and
the day of the quarter then it will and
you can pass that that to this
transformer then it will generate you
that information often that's this
example probably will not be of a very
useful often but depends on on the
question you are trying to tackle
so putting it all together
here we have
this forecasting pipeline you can say
okay i have certain dynamics for my
events for the holidays i want maybe i'm
interested in different lags so here in
this quarks argument i i can specify
then um what kind of
features i'm interested in then maybe
another column i want to specify other
information in so you have a for the
snap day you have a days you of certain
other dynamics and you can implement
that as a next step in the forecasting
pipeline then you add on top of the
daytime features in this case daily data
and then finally you have your
forecaster
we talked about it that within that
forecaster this is this make reduction
function where we then apply the windows
summarizes we want to apply to the y to
help the model understand
the time series dynamics
and then finally you can fit that and it
will then return
your forecasts
that correspond to the structure
of the time series that you uh provided
exactly um
so here you can see in this case two
products you will get individual
forecasts for these two products
um what is the road ahead what uh we
implemented and what we thought was
relevant with regards to global
forecasting is if you stay time features
with the summarizer the hierarchical
data type these adjustments to reduce to
allow an efficient and performance
intensive
useful implementation that is
parallelized
because often these problems can become
so huge and that the performance is very
important
one area of further research that we
have would be cross validation
because you saw we have we can specify
this dictionary but that's of course a
quite manual task
so typically there's some expertise you
have you can of course for
cross-validation provide all kinds of
dictionaries but typically you want to
be to have that
generated and here we are
talking about different approaches
one would be for example to auto detect
based on current autocorrelation and
seasonality what kind of features you
really then generate ultimately or also
you can take a look at the feature
importances to identify relevant
features so that would be then more like
an automated tuning strategies strategy
other things that we are talking about
is extrapolation and time series that's
of course very important but not really
supported by tree based models
okay
um thanks and there are um
some methods to help you um to help
these models extrapolate
you can talk about trend removal and
addition here again then the question is
do you want to remove trends in each
individual time series do you want to
identify common trains and remove them
commonly and add them up after that
um
[Music]
but you can also
do some post-processing so here we are
still discussing discussing uh what we
where we want to go as a next snap
and of course
quanta regression um
so
for example at the m5 this was a split
competition we had point forecast but we
also had quantile forecasts these three
based models uh performed best for both
both of these um challenges and that's
what uh france already uh showed us and
here um that is however currently also
not supported so that's some uh things
where um we of course are also very
interested in any uh additional
contributors uh that would uh
try to or would would support us in that
regard
uh and finally we talk about the
extension guide here you can build your
own hierarchical forecaster here is some
guidance on how to do that
we always have this check estimator
function that will run you through all
the tests that are relevant in this
regards if you want to implement
anything on your own that's very helpful
and of course for hierarchical type you
would then specify the correct inner m
type we talked about it
especially multi-index multi and x
hierarchical
and um yeah that's that's i think a
guide on how to proceed here if anyone
is interested and here we also come now
to the next point
france
and i think we're approaching the end of
our presentation just to reiterate this
as we've said at the start sk time is
very much a community based project
we're looking very much after our
contributors and try to involve them
in
community operations as well as events
this summer we'll have the google summer
of code applications are still possible
until april 19. you can sign up for
mentoring
and
community collaboration sessions on
fridays you can join them on
discord just drop in
and say hello
we have an onboarding event may 25-27
and the yearly developer sprint on
june 27 to july 1.
any
questions thanks a lot for the for the
presentation and yes we have a few
questions on sliders
we have a bit of time for question i
will go first on the so can i maybe
quickly say a thing so i've seen people
try to run the notebook that currently
will break on binder because that relies
on conda and the newest version is not
yet out in conda so you need to use
either the developer version or a pip
install that should work
once the release is on conda the binder
should also run
ah well uh we have uh so please raise
that then in the uh community channels
on slack and or on the razer bug report
on sk time
uh yeah i've seen some some people here
in the audience uh encountering that one
issue is often um the profit library uh
you don't you you you need to pay
attention to what is a hard dependency
and what is the software dependency if
your operating system is windows right
pip install if you install with all
extras does not work on windows with all
extras so if you go to the
installation instructions
there is a specific sequence of commands
you need to run for windows if you want
all the soft dependencies yeah so that's
not related to sk time but some
dependencies have yeah yeah okay but
not
something we can fix let's say like that
it's hot off the presses and maybe there
is a bug
let's come to the questions
okay question uh yeah we have a few
questions on slido the first question
how many layers of hierarchy are
supported in escape time
arbitrary number of
so the the hierarchical data type
at least by definition
supports three or more layers of course
not every algorithm
will be able to deal with that
a second
question from anonymous is it possible
to access the parameters of the specific
models for example would i be able to
get profit trend holiday coefficient
through sktime
yes
so sk time supports the get and set
params interface of scikit-learn and is
fully compatible with that
if you use get params with the deep
argument you get you can see all the
parameters so you mean hyper parameters
or the fitted parameters you have to
so some estimators implement the get
fitted params
method
that is all that is though not
implemented with nesting as you may have
to look through the underscore
attributes if you're looking for fitted
parameters
i
i have then a question about a type
error
when
the sktime version 0.11.1
is installed and yeah it raiser type
error outfit with an unexpected
uh keyword argument fh
but maybe it's something that can be
erased somewhere else
open the bug report yeah
yeah is visualization of hierarchical
time series supported in ascii time or
is it even possible it's not support it
would be a nice thing to have so
open an issue with a feature request or
contributed yourself by pull request
defining meaningful thresholds for the
windows summarizer is an art any support
from sktime to evaluate the most
suitable time window yeah that's what we
discussed uh and where we uh want to go
um we have different approaches we
discussed here one would be like a hand
daily do you provide a complexity
argument you provide your frequency that
you have and then some common useful
things would be implemented but ideally
of course you want to have some
detection about that we have some ideas
on how to proceed here but there's
nothing currently implemented that's
that's what i mentioned it's really a
kind of a art currently so we don't have
an out of the box solution here the
interesting roadmap item
extending grid search
and
evaluation for hierarchical data types
so having the having the windows
splitter grid search and evaluation
integrated then you could tune for
instance
okay
next question do you have any support
for scaling like multi-process
multi-processing usage in cloud spark
etc for profit there are some resources
resources for setting it up in respite
spark
not directly no of course you can always
embed your code and there is
parallelization which some estimators
implement but there is not this
overarching framework just to run it on
pi spark it is a it seems it sounds like
a big effort and there's we're getting a
lot of requests for that but of course
we're a volunteer-driven project mostly
so that might be something for the next
big road map period
okay
assuming you have daily data and retain
once a week such that during
cross-validation you can predict a full
week at once how do you deal with gaps
from forecast horizon
uh gaps in the forecast horizon yeah
fc
it can have gaps yeah some
an estimator
the interface the interface requires
that you can implement
so that the forecast horizon can have
gaps of course a number of estimators
can't deal with that so what in this
case we do we just fill in the gaps and
then remove them again but that is
really the estimator's business yeah
then like
sorry last question i have on slido
thanks for the great presentation i
would like to know if i can use sktime
to denounce time series
ah denoising
so okay so that's an interesting topic
we have an open issue on the noising and
things like the kalman filter
you could use
currently pca or hampel filter
yeah we we have about
bug reports around it so you may want to
try
and kalman is a contribution
as an interface to happen hopefully it's
not that well supported at the moment
right so it might be a nice thing again
to contribute
we still have five minutes to take one
or two questions in the audience if oh
you could use exponential smoothing in
sample you could use exponential
smoothing example that would also work
okay i see some questions
hi
do you already have an interface to glue
on ts for instance for hierarchical
forecasting no it's an open issue okay
so
it's one of the big things
on on the
police interface list
pull requests
so
i
see that you had some models with
hidden variables for instance
you talk about canon filters
but
is it possible to share hidden variables
between
different panel data
or different time series
okay the hit i mean that's a model
concern so there's no abstract interface
element which allows you to share fitted
parameters between the models of course
you can implement it for your model but
then you would need to wrap it in the
general interface there is also a
it's a parameter extractor is a
transformer
which you could
so which you can use in feature
extraction and it takes out of the
forecaster i think the the parameters
but that might not be exactly what what
you want
is it
okay so you want models to share
parameters between
yeah it's an interesting question
whether that can how that would look on
a framework level sharing parameters
between models because then you would
also need to have a model that inputs so
where do you input the parameters and
then how does the other model know what
parameters it's getting
okay maybe one more question interesting
okay
yeah
over a data science question um
like we have these time daytime features
like week of the year or something
and then you have the problem that one
is very close to 52 or something
like what is your
uh do you have a suggestion how to deal
with it i know there's like xenos and
coziness encoding for it yeah but like
just because you deal with these things
probably so maybe you have an idea
what's a good solution so this fourier
terms approach is an alternative way
where you have more smoothness between
the the different realizations right so
i'm not sure about i completely got your
question but for example if you if a day
of the week
monday and tuesday are more linked and
not really independent than you can use
fourier terms and that's a thing that we
uh talk about
or that we want to implement but it's
currently not supported so currently you
have these dummy features and that's
basically everything is independent if
you think there's some sort of
smoothness then that's
was that a question or yeah
we did have fully introduced somewhere
didn't we have 48 yeah i think we have a
free transformation but the fourier
terms to be used in that way i'm not
sure about yeah but you would just put
it wouldn't you just put it in the make
reduction and then you use it as a
transformer then those fourier terms are
added as a column to the to the
exogenous thing i have a like a
development version for this daytime
features similar to for this real times
but i have not implemented yet yeah but
three features are i think already in
yeah okay i'm not sure about that yeah
and then you could yeah you could plug
it in okay yeah i just want to plug it
in yeah you don't know all the functions
it might of course break but in theory
uh you would plug it
i still have it on you take the full
reference fourier feature transformer
and plug it into the transformers
argument of the make reduction
thanks a lot again to the to the speaker
and the presentation today